foreign
Boston I guess it sounds better when
it's Roxanne what's up Rachel
hi John how's how are you I I yeah we
were partying literally partying how
about you
have to be on this call but is it about
him
it is about him oh yes why isn't he on
right now well it's what he gets for
having a job we get to talk about him
all right so what did you do
okay um so my question is how can my
fiance make solid friendships
um and so I wrote in because I know how
important it is to have solid
friendships to spend time with and show
up for each other whenever there's a
need my fiancee and I are getting
married at the end of this month and
he's been disappointed by many of his
groomsmen who are the closer friends
that he has but over the years I haven't
seen them reach out or do anything that
wasn't convenient for them
my fiance is so thoughtful and always
willing to help in ways that amaze me he
doesn't receive the same level of care
that he puts out for them it's coming to
the point where he'll say I don't need
anyone anyway and that makes me really
sad and also concerns me
um he is so deserving of great
friendships so my question is how can he
find and develop better friendships to
create a solid group of guy friends
so can I ask you a personal question
you promise you'll answer
yeah that sounded like the most eloquent
way of saying I don't like my husband's
friends
yeah do you hate his friends
um that's a strong word I wouldn't say
that I know because you're an eloquent
kind of person but do you hate his
friends
I still don't think I would say hey
Jesus
so ridiculous do you strongly dislike
them
uh no even worse even worse you know
what you don't I don't think you hate
him I think you're disappointed by them
I'm disappointed that's the word yeah
like like you're their third grade
teacher I'm just disappointed in you
boys oh yeah so are these is like ride
or die buddies have been around for a
long time
uh some of them yes some of them it's
been yeah they've all known him longer
than I've known him
um how much of that is plays into this
here's why and and you can tell me I'm
wrong
it is not uncommon for a fiance to come
in and be jealous of the one thing that
a group of friends that an ex-girlfriend
or an ex-boyfriend they're always going
to have this one thing no matter what we
could have kids we could have a home we
could have whatever
they will always have this one thing on
us time
they'll always have those jokes I wasn't
a part of they always have these
get-togethers I wasn't there for you
always have this one time they all got
drunk and they did this or that one time
that
is that part of it
no okay
you promise
yes okay so really in all honesty if you
mind your soul
if these guys were ride or die and he
was hanging out with him once a week or
once every couple of weeks or whatever
that would feel that would fill you up
yes okay
and so you're watching somebody that you
love get treated like crap is what's
what basically is boiled down to
yeah okay
the unfortunate answer here is you can
do nothing for him
he's got to choose that he's worthy of
having friends that actually are worth
being friends
and that's hard
you don't like that answer
um I wish I could do something but I do
recognize that it's up to him do you
have friends
oh I have the most amazing friends I'm
very blessed okay
what is it about him that he doesn't see
himself as worthy of having friends
um I'm
picked on and he was kind of
left out of everything so he doesn't
have the most the highest self-esteem in
that area okay
is there some of your friends
partners that he could hang out with
like do y'all do couple stuff sounds so
gross when I say that
um
no not in this area
they're all kind of spread out across
the country
so I would tell you you're gonna need to
make new friends in your area also
and so you're you're how old are you
25 25 okay so here's what's going to
happen and I'm gonna paint you a very
depressing picture is that okay
okay all right so your entire life since
you were zero has been curated
you go to elementary school you go to
pre-k or kindergarten and then
elementary school and they put you on
the same row like you're on the red
robins row and you're on the uh the
tennis racket row or whatever and and
you're on the baseballs you're in the
basketballs whatever
and then you go to elementary school and
it's like
some of you play kickball and then some
of you hate kickball and then those
become your friends and the the like
sweaty dudes are like yeah bro we're all
in the Kickball like they become friends
and then you go to music music class and
it's like Tata and some people like oh
my gosh and some people like their soul
lights up
and then it goes to middle school and
then high school and then you get into
theater into sports or whatever your
thing is or doing nothing is your thing
and then you go to college and you have
a major and a sorority or uh whatever
the thing everything is is optimized for
you
you go to the military you go to
Community College and you have group
projects whatever the thing is
and then you get out into the real world
and you get married and you move to your
new town and the whole it's all you
versus the whole world
what do you do for a living
me yes
um I
I switching jobs okay what are you gonna
be what are you going to be doing
uh camp director okay so if you get
somebody to go to your camp
it's gonna because it's gonna be because
they didn't go to somebody else's camp
and that other Camp is going to put
promotional materials and come up with
new rides and new like learning
objectives or whatever to get kids from
your Camp to go to their camp
and you're going to spend your time
trying to get kids to go to your camp
and take care of those kids that are at
your camp
see what I'm saying it's you versus the
world now
and you're gonna have to find your
friends your ride or die your best
friends in the world they're going to
get married and they're going to have
families and it's going to turn into
weekly calls or everyday calls turn into
weekly calls turn into text turn into
long strings of emojis and funny back
and forths
and maybe annual get-togethers and then
buy annual get-togethers
and if you're not careful you wake up
and you're 33
and you and your husband are sitting on
the same couch and he's on ESPN fantasy
sports and you are researching pallet
walls or whatever it is you're into
see what I'm saying and what I just
painted you I just painted you the
picture of the American life right now
as we're all living it
unless you get hyperintentional you
Rachel get hyperintentional about making
friends in your new area new friends new
relationships new Rider dies
and
if you make that a part of your life
your husband's gonna have to not choose
to opt in he's gonna have to choose to
opt out of that
and it's easier to opt it's harder to
opt out of something it is to opt in
see what I'm saying so I'm what I'm
telling you is the greatest gift you can
give him is the practice of making new
friends hey once a week we're going to
have somebody over
we're going to have a messy house and we
don't even care and we're going to meet
a couple of people that we work with
we're going to meet a couple people at a
local church or at the gym or whatever
wherever we meet folks and we're just
going to be weird and we're going to go
first
and I've made some of my life's best
friends doing that and I've had some of
the most awkward worst interactions of
my life doing that too
does that sound nutty
that sounds like really good advice but
it's also depressing like in a yeah not
in a like clinical way but it's a it's
like I want to be friends with my
friends forever
um I did something this past weekend so
I went to Texas for some speaking events
and
um I had four events in three days
and I went a day early I just turned in
a book draft I'm ex I am exhausted out
of my mind and I went to hang out with
some of my 30 year old friends my oldest
friends on the planet
um
two guys that um I trust with everything
in my life
and I haven't lived in this city for
five years now
and
the first thing I got off the airplane
and I traveled so much I lived in this
community for 20 years and I couldn't
quite remember the right exit I remember
thinking whoa that's weird
and then we all hung out and their kids
were old I didn't even recognize two of
their kids when they walked in the room
I was like oh my gosh they got old
and then I I realized like we are still
best friends I still love those guys I
love their wives I love their kids like
they're my own
and we have very different lives now
and it was a sense of grief and a sense
of mourning and a sense of loss you know
what I mean
yeah because we did everything together
all the time
always
um even something as simple as I went in
the garage and my first I was like when
did y'all get these cars and why didn't
you tell me and then it's like oh cause
you live 2 000 miles away idiot right
like I'm outside of that little Loop
that's gonna be your life whether you
want it to or not and so if you're
intentional about what comes next it's a
totally different ride than if you just
it happens to you and suddenly you wake
up and it's gone
right does that make sense
yeah
and if you're watching your husband get
beat up all the time
there is something profound about
sitting across from a man
and holding his hand and look at him in
the eye and saying
you're an absolute badass and you're
worth more than this
and I'm proud of you and I want you to
find men who respect you like I do
see what I'm saying
yeah I was married for 15 years before I
um had the courage and I was embarrassed
to do it because I was ashamed
to tell my wife hey it would mean the
world to me if you just called out that
you're proud of me
and it was like I was tearful I was
weeping I was like man I can't believe
I'm having to say this out loud not that
she hadn't said it but I'm I can't
believe that this means something to me
and it did
and it when she was like oh my gosh I
wish I'd known because I'm so proud of
you I tell everybody I just didn't know
that was a thing that you needed to hear
I felt weird
um it was a reorientation for me like I
could stand up a little bit taller
and when people blow me off or they're
uglier they're rude or whatever like I
can move on with my day because I got
her by my side does that make sense
yeah there's like a reinforcing thing
and I know that sounds weird that you
don't want to be the person reinforcing
him but man it's a powerful thing to
have a woman who loves you look across
the table and say I believe in you and
you're worth more than this nonsense
is that fair
yeah I'm throwing a lot at you what do
you think back
I feel like I freaked you out a little
bit Rachel
what's he gonna say if you sit down and
tell him that
proud of him yep
yeah but I mean mean it
and tell him that he's worth good
friends
[Laughter]
keep telling him yeah I I I can do it
more often
awesome
he's lucky to have you I want you to be
um
worried about the things that you can
control
which unfortunately are not how many
friends he chooses to have
what you can control is how many new
relationships and new friends you make
in your new town at your new job in your
new community in this new life you're
building together with your fiance
that is what you can control
and invite him along for every step of
the way
and don't make him go to weird things
where people wear super short shorts and
boat shoes but like cool things I don't
know that may be cool for you guys and
don't make him play golf but like invite
him to cool stuff
and give him a voice
but make friends a part of y'all's new
life together
and a promise he'll pick up that baton
and make friendship and connection an
important part of his life too
thank you for loving him so much man the
world needs more fiances like you